actually here's a fun fact you want to
get a little like first and nobody else
has gotten where I star Antony parofsky
spilling the tea about Taylor Swift's
you need to calm down music video
[Music]
but first he's telling only ET about the
time he almost landed a part in Taylor's
video for blank space I auditioned for
that when I was a waiter and I got
called back twice and it was between me
and two other guys and at the audition I
had to pretend like I was running away
from a lion on a green screen and I told
her that they ended up changing the
direction and Shawn oak trees did a very
fantastic job so I did have a first
chance at a Taylor Swift music video and
I didn't get it and so now I felt like
Phoenix Rising redemption and I got to
actually be in one the TV personality
confirmed that Taylor personally asked
him to be in the video she's very much
in control of her whole creative process
while she is very collaborative I love
the way that she communicates with
everybody on production it's very much a
vision that she has and I think that
that's so admirable and I see that with
a lot of creative women and I think men
can really learn from strong women and
like media and like in pop culture who
are actually doing that I think it's
really freaking dope and I respect her
tremendously it was so much fun
there was the sets like there's details
on that set that you probably couldn't
even see in the video everything was so
carefully curated like it was sign
English bone china with a porcelain that
we were drinking from there was a little
a little honey bear from the 1930s that
was solid glass to use to like sweet
parties like every single little thing
she didn't even play the music but she
keeps she runs a tight ship and she's
written about this and spoken about this
like she she really wants her fans to
have that moment of discovery
when she comes up with a new song or a
new album and she keeps it super hush
and then it's just this beautiful
explosion and then fans around the world
get to rejoice so the song was not
playing on set like she wanted all of us
to enjoy it when it came out and when
the video finally dropped Antony
celebrated for many reasons I saw the
video and I freaked out I thought it was
so cool so I didn't even know everybody
else that was in it and just to see all
of these like wonderful lgbtqia+
personalities and allies were featured
in the video is like like she doesn't
have to do that and she does and I
really respect that the message of the
video was about inclusivity and really
promoting lgbtqia+ talent and allies and
I think she did a tremendously good
respectful job in doing
[Music]
[Applause]